all right today's topic
[Applause]
why didn't you apologize to chris in
your acceptance speech
um
i was fogged out by that point
it's it's it's it's all fuzzy i've
reached out to
chris um and the mesh the message that
came back is that uh he's not ready to
talk
and when he is
he will
reach out
um
so i will i will say to you
uh
chris
i
apologize
to you
uh my behavior
was
unacceptable
and i'm here
whenever you're ready to talk
um
i i want to apologize to
chris's mother
i saw an interview that chris's mother
did
and you know that was one of the things
about that moment i just didn't realize
and you know i wasn't thinking but how
many people got hurt
in that moment
so i want to apologize to chris's mother
i want to apologize to uh chris's family
uh specifically tony rock you know we
had a great relationship
you know tony rock was my man um
and uh this is this is probably
irreparable
um
i spent the last
three months
um replaying
and
understanding the nuances and and the
complexities of what happened
someone said to me uh
i don't get why tony rock so mad like if
y'all was friends i could make it work
life don't work like that
yo
yo if you slap my brother on national
television embarrassing my whole family
you [ __ ] dead to me
you think imma go up here and buddy up
with you
when you
it's not just my [ __ ] got slapped
he gets people coming after him and
talking to him about it everywhere he
goes he got a reliv getting punked on
national television everywhere he goes
and you
can we talk
like
maybe you you want to say like i don't
think people recognize how emasculating
it is to get smacked in front of other
people and you don't do [ __ ]
you know that you know that [ __ ] meme
of kevin hart pacing like
next time
next time when i see a [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you replaying scenarios you
think about what you're going to do what
kind of
like that
because it's that infuriating that
somebody crossed your physical
boundaries and put their hands on you
like that that's not light that's not
light work
this is why i tell people don't get
physically violent with folks because
you don't understand how much that can
escalate from there it's cool till it's
not
you get what i'm trying to say
so yeah if you do that to my brother i
don't care how tight like
no
until my brother cool with you i don't
even think i could even open that door
he did i believe that will set the right
thing
whenever you're gonna be ready i'm gonna
be there that readiness
may never happen you smack my sister on
nationals you must match me that's
exactly how my sister because i don't
have a brother
um
those who know me know what the [ __ ] is
gonna happen next
i i don't need to put it on yo i'm not
going to advertise that i don't know if
you agree with me i would have rather a
[ __ ] punch me than slap me you
got [ __ ] slap yeah okay so i want you
guys to understand when you smack
somebody like that like a man smacks
another man like that that's a show of
dominance
you throw hands with somebody that's
like it's a fight
when you know you above somebody you
smack the [ __ ] out of them
smacking is what you do to your child
that's why parents don't be out here
punching their kids unless it's a real
beating if they want you to put your
place they smack you to be like that's
why i wouldn't even hate it more if a
grown man try to be like this to me i'd
rather a [ __ ] punch me so we can
go at it than this
my face
don't touch my face
but isn't it worse though you get it it
is even even even putting your hands on
my chin putting don't touch my phone you
understand absolutely that's what i'm
saying yeah that's what i'm saying look
at that look at him getting heated
it's just me imagining just some random
[ __ ]
touching my kevin hart as another
[ __ ] kid about that okay which is
weird
it's going to be a girl but you
understand it's a funny skit to me you
know some people don't like kevin hart i
like you
no it's not even that it's whenever he
has a bagel and he's in new york he's in
new york and then uh and then
a homeless person takes his bagel but
then a finger touches his lip and he
loses his [ __ ]
shout out okay shout out kevin hart all
right
in in that moment um
and
i'm not going to try to unpack all of
that right now but i can say to
all of you there is no part of me
that thinks that was the right way
to
behave
in that moment
there's no part of me that thinks that's
the optimal way
to
handle
a feeling of disrespect or or insults
after jada rolled her eyes did she tell
you to do something
no
it's like
you know i'm i made a choice
on my own
from my own experiences from
my
history with chris jada had nothing to
do with it
i'm sorry babe
um
and say sorry to my my kids and
my family
for the heat that i brought on
you trying to protect your wife
and some people might see it as an
admirable thing like i said in the last
video when you're trying to protect
someone who constantly throws you under
the bus publicly
why that might be a sign of loyalty to a
lot of us it just looks like you simply
we're going to look at you
it's going to it's was she was she
protecting you when she brought you on a
red table talk to talk about that
entanglement
was that protection or the fact that you
you can't make her come
that's [ __ ] up
yo listen but you know some people make
they think putting this [ __ ] out there
me putting my i don't put my [ __ ] out
there to me i'm not gonna lie will just
strikes me as a person who's a giver and
gives and gives and gives and gives and
that's where they you know i understand
it's not it's not a bad thing to be a
giver until you get somebody who just
wants to take more than you got to give
boom
boom you know it's like a well
if you don't let that [ __ ] run there's
no water for nobody to drink boom will
look like somebody all dried out boom
look at him don't even look
don't don't he looks like he pruned out
my doctor told me that i needed to get
like more nutriments and more vitamins
so he told me to take
some vitamins and the vitamins
let's be honest
who does that the pills are big and it
is what it is i'm not doing that and
this is where aj won by athletic greens
comes into play look at this
every day you can just put a little
scoop of powder in 12 ounces of water
and you're good once every day and it
costs you less than a beer or coffee so
you can get starting today to get your
vitamins up and going and be able to
work out and be able to do all of
everything that you need to do in your
day athletic greens is here to make it
easy for you
with your first purchase they will give
you one year supply of immune supporting
vitamins yeah vitamin d plus five free
travel packs if you go on
atlantagreens.com
abba and preach drink some aj1 to get
the stuff that you need
go about today
all of us
um to all my fellow nominees you know
this is a community it's like i won
because you you voted for me and it it
really breaks my heart to have stolen
and and tarnished tarnished your moment
yeah you know speaking all the nominees
all the actors present you know [ __ ] all
y'all y'all can say we'll suck some dick
and i'll say this
for hollywood to be so [ __ ]
virtuosically about everything violence
blah blah blah i watched a grown man
assault somebody else on national
television and sat in your seats and
clapped for him vigorously when he got
his award everyone tacitly endorsed
violence against dudes just because they
like the actor involved or because a
woman was offended by a joke that's what
happened so as far as all the others act
i don't care if it's denzel i don't care
who the [ __ ] it is they all sat in that
room and gave him a standing ovation
when he went to get up his ward they had
time to reflect see what happened and
everyone kept quiet so anytime an actor
wants to come out and say guys there's
volunteer there's violence there i'm
always gonna think back at that moment
and how quiet everybody [ __ ] was in
that room when violence happened right
in front of them that's all i'm going to
say
what would you say to the people who
looked up to you
before the slap or people who expressed
that you let them down
so there's two things one
um
disappointing people is my central
trauma
um i hate
when
i let people down
um so
it
what you said the giving thing yep
it hurts and and if
i don't want to keep psychologists but
it's it's something that often happened
when when
when new an individual uh feels left out
by either a family member or whatever
what not so they feel like they need to
give in order to be worthy worthy to be
like you know what i mean
they they need to fill that gap like a
bit a bit of
like i need to give so that people don't
leave me i don't need to don't
disappoint not disappoint in order for
people not to leave me like maybe that
person lived because i disappointed them
sometimes it's something that's
internalized like that again i don't
want to play psychologists i'm not one
i'm just telling you
what i know about the situation that is
very recurrent and and that situation is
a bit similar
uh it hurts me psychologically and
emotionally to know i didn't live up to
uh people's
image and impression of me
and
the work i'm trying to do is
i am
deeply remorseful
and i'm trying to be remorseful without
being ashamed of myself
right i'm human
and
i made
a mistake
and
let me unpack that
trying to be remorseful without being
ashamed
let me ask you
is being ashamed of bad thing
well the feeling is bad
but it's not hold on
but it's not
i don't believe it's a bad thing
it's part of a cycle
it's a bad feeling that we have so we
link it to something being bad
that's why it's something being negative
you know what i mean but
it's a negative feeling right
but in my perspective when you're
ashamed
like rem
there's a bit of shame in remorse not
all the time
but
when indeed those kind of situations
when you are sorry about something that
you did there there's shame in there i
think
and i think
being ashamed
yeah being ashamed is part of remorse
because you have to go through that in
order to be like i'm resourceful because
there's that feeling that i feel that i
want to feel that i know it's bad so
that that that that shame that you have
is the thing that's like [ __ ] i know is
the feeling that makes you know that the
thing that you did was bad like i didn't
want to do that because i don't want to
be the representation so the shame
is very linked to me it's linked to
remorse it is and it's actually
um
essential
for you to be able to redeem yourself so
you have to go through that step of
remorse
uh uh of shame to go through that
process of remorse and being able to
redeem yourself
what shame can be defined as the feeling
of embarrassment humiliation
that arises in relation to the
perception of having done something
dishonorable immoral or improper
by such a definition 100 percent you
should feel ashamed and there's not to
bash on you i'm just trying to explain
that like
shame is not inherently a terrible thing
if you do something that is shameful
it's okay to sit in there and be like
i'm ashamed of what i've done and then
go from there to not we have to relive
that shame i'm not saying you ought to
slap
flagellate and do all this stuff but i
think shame is not necessarily a bad
thing and that's the thing that whenever
you know someone that does a crime
and they did what they say is that they
show no remorse
when someone doesn't show any remorse
he's not ashamed of what he did he did
what he did and i did what i did that's
it i'm not ashamed yeah when someone's
gonna be like hey
lock me up but i'll do it again you have
no shame he's not he's not shame he's
not he's not remorseful he's not so he's
not able to redeem himself because he
doesn't go through that process of of of
being ashamed and having remorse he
doesn't
i'm trying not to think of myself as a
piece of [ __ ]
um
so i would say to those people i know
it was confusing i know it was shocking
um
but i i promise you
i am
deeply devoted and committed to putting
light and love and joy
into the world and
you know
if you if you hang on i promise we'll be
able to be friends again
the last part i don't really i'm not
really quite sure who he's talking to if
you hang on and and i i don't know who's
probably talking to
the public but we're like we're not
friends
well you're not that accessible all
right the other day this is for chris to
forgive him not me
you know my
image of will's been dead for a while
you know
all right this is weird to lose you know
there's not many people you look up to
but when you grow up in an age with not
too many media figures and you got just
you know like you know when i was living
in ethiopia we had like arab satellite
and there was like two tv shows that i
used to watch it's jamie fox show and
the fresh prince about it and for me
just seeing like black folks on tv not
necessarily hacking a fool but being
eloquent and being diverse and being
interesting like will was a big deal at
the time that's why so many people kind
of revere him in a lot of ways and
revere the fresh prince it was a great
television show um
and so
i'm over my disappointment and the world
doesn't own me anything go live your
life
um but as far as his behavior
i don't know i just
i gotta appreciate the fact that will
didn't [ __ ] do an apology whereas
like i'm sorry that but it's because my
man ain't trying to explain why like
he didn't try to explain why did it he
just acknowledged that he did something
bad
all the apologies of all the stars are
all the [ __ ] same i'm sorry i did
that but it's because no
i i
i appreciate the fact that you just did
that you just said you were sorry you
[ __ ] up
like abba says it's for
chris to forgive you
and we'll see maybe he's never going to
forgive you that's for him to know
it's not so much the fact that he didn't
do nothing he can't do anything
he can't reply back you can't hit
someone back at national tv
now
i still appreciate will and i can
understand that a human being can [ __ ]
up
that was a pretty bad [ __ ] up my dude
and
we'll see for the rest who was really
see for the rest
well as of right now you're doing all
the steps but
oh that one is a heavy one man
slapping a heavy like slapping a
slapping a a co-worker like that a
brother or someone that you're cool with
like that
i've dropped friends for less than that
for less than that
oh they deserved it
maybe the minute you get physical
it's a whole rap
but then again you know feelings and
stuff like that whatever
i should have a hard time comprehending
like
no i don't understand you're a giver
you want to ride for your people ride
for your family failure is not an option
divorce is not an option so you right
for your people writing or written
regardless
it's [ __ ] up that the people that are
closest to you you're willing for them
to
disrespect you the most
but when you
when those people that disrespect you
get disrespected once
you lose it
so if you gave a slap
to chris
what should jada get
that's not for me to decide but i mean
the way he was disrespecting her the way
she was disrespecting him a lot all all
those time
all the time he's been throwing he's
been thrown under the bus by jada
but then one person is going to touch
jada to talk about jada's head
and he's going to lose it
you know how weird that is
that's weird b
anyway that's not for me to decide
that's for you that's
your demons your demons your closet your
thing man whatever bro you know i wrote
a drug where i said